les succès ça on n'avait pas anticipé à
ce point en tout cas
[Musique]
ça renvoie une image qui est super pour
le gaming et pour tout ce qu'on fait
dans le streaming
quand il faut se réunir pour pour le
bien on sait le faire
sans public ont derrière cet événement
il existe que grâce au public et c'est
juste fou que les gens soient soient
réunis autour d'une cause qui est
positive si pasteur voyez ça aujourd'hui
il en serait je pense
extrêmement ému et reconnaissant on va
faire trembler l'univers va se faire
entendre
croyez moi bien
bon déjà merci à tous d'être là vraiment
c'est cela qui a commencé sur une note
positive de servir je sais qu'à des
problèmes de net etc
on fait au mieux merci pour votre
patience on va essayer de régler ça dans
les temps en tout cas merci de répondre
présent comme chaque année bienvenue aux
nouveaux on est content de vous avoir
[Applaudissements]
normalement je pense vous connaissez le
principe ya pas de grosses guideline on
vous fait globalement confiance pour
gérer votre planning a essayé quand même
dans la mesure du possible de respecter
la seule consigne qui était on dépasse
pas 25 heures de live d'affilée en stop
si vous avez les moyens le but c'est pas
de faire les [ __ ] à cliquer machin mais
encouragé vraiment les gens à faire des
dons même de 1 euro je préfère que vous
soyez 10000 20000 à donner 1 euro que
10000 20000 à rien faire parce que vous
pouvez pas donné grand chose n'hésitez
pas à red les autres pour aller voir
leurs donations de gaulle et donner
envie à vos viewers donnée celle
notamment chez calmes et obtiendrait en
vélo à feurs 0 voilà à 18h vous venez
tous derrière moi sur la chaise comme
d'habitude pour ceux qui connaissent moi
je vais dire salut c'est énorme on lance
dit event est en gros je dis allez vous
pouvez y aller go et là tout le monde va
sur son ordi et là vous pouvez allumer
vos live à ce moment là avec la canal
[Musique]
or les i even c'est un événement qui
durera week-end où on se retrouve à
plein de streamer en l'occurrence 56
chacun lance sa chaîne en direct on joue
à des jeux vidéo ont fait des quizz on
chante on fait la musique on fait plein
de bêtises et le but c'est de lever des
fonds pour une association cette année
ces instituts pasteur l'année dernière
c'était à médecins sans frontières avec
une 1 millions d'euros récoltés
j'adore accueillir les gens et j'espère
que tout le monde va bien s'y sentir et
mon oeuvre vraiment mon gros objectif
c'est que tout le monde reparte avec des
étoiles dans les yeux
oubliez pas de sénateur est toléré dans
encore plus que l'an dernier on est
énormément nombreux donc toujours pour
soutenir la bonne cause bien sûr donc
plus on est plus on va rire déjà et
surtout plus on va ramasser j'espère de
donation et exploser le record des 1
millions de l'an dernier
question qu'il faut durer avec lésions
qui vont beaucoup discuté à des gens qui
vont faire de la musique est menée par
exemple fait du jeu vidéo mais l' an
dernier son titre incontournable j'adore
le ce boom avait affolé la toile
j'ai vu
donc voilà chacun il va un petit peu de
son petit truc et mais il n'ya pas que
du jeu vidéo en effet c'est du partage
avant tout on est souvent très seul en
fait dans mes de streaming parce qu'on
est tous devant nos pc et là on se
retrouve tous ensemble qu'on met une
grosse colonie de vacances on a tout vu
des gaules
moi je sais que je vais jouer à un jeu
qui s'appelle or au troc qui est un jeu
de simulation de camions alors ça peut
paraître ultra relou comme ça mais en
fait moi j'aime bien écraser les
voitures conduire très mal donc c'est
très drôle j'ai ramené le volant
extérieur pourrait beaucoup traîné sur
les lives des autres on prévoit beaucoup
de choses en général mais le week-end
passé très très vite
du coup ça va être vraiment
l'improvisation aussi des trucs est
vachement importance je trouve c'est en
tout cas sur le stream c'est
l'improvisation c'est le fait de pas
trop prévoir ce qu'on fait et surtout
interagir avec tous les gens qui sont
ici ça serait ça serait un peu dommage
voilà deux d'être ici et de faire comme
si y'avait personne n'ose tu vois
[Musique]
c'est devant la fois 2-1 bonsoir
bienvenue à zielona derrière moi
ah ça fait ça fait plus de rugby du
hockey vous voyez on est on est très
nombreux ça devient de plus en plus
divisé le chacun et faire rentrer tout
le monde dans cette caméra on a essayé
de faire le maximum qu'on pouvait tout
le monde est là tout le monde est prêt
sur ses live donc je déclare j -mt 2019
ouvert et vous pouvez vous pouvez aller
lime un volume presse privée tout le
monde va se déplacer et aller
directement sur soleil
[Musique]
s'emballe bob le passage son ballon en
échange
5 jenson
tu as fait un effort sur la qualité la
caméra j'ai l'impression c'est faux
les gens arrivent ici on voit toutes les
personnes qui tombent et 11 actuellement
cet écran est très important c'est
pourquoi c'est pourtant un regard des
pannes mais le début c'est dingue ça
part très très près au milieu demain par
exemple se balançait beaucoup
pour les 250 dates
pour que ça ressemble à la bourse de new
york c'est un sac ça me fait penser
c'est le moment préféré le début de la
fin c'est l'avenir plus d'activités et
où
l'ambiance est partout autour de nous et
a le droit permanent je suis pas fan non
mesdames et messieurs
[Applaudissements]
milady leeuwen fait l'historique remonte
à 2016 ou en fait
adrien et plusieurs autres streamer du
marché français faisait partie d'un
collectif qui s'appelle avengers le
principe d'avengers c'est que le
collectif réagi en situation de crise et
d'urgence pour soutenir des causes qui
sont pas très médiatisé et donc c'est
adrien qu'avait eu cette idée qui m'a
dit ah ce serait cool qu'on a envie de
quelques potes et qu'on se fasse un truc
à la maison tout simple ou voilà on se
fait du stream en groupe une petite lana
notre manière et à et on joue tous
ensemble pour récolter des fonds
tout premier donc avengers on était
peut-être 12 13 chez zerator donc à
l'ancien vraiment en mode la petite lan
entre entre potes sauf que c'est pour du
caritatif on avec plein de gens ici chez
moi dans la petite maison regarder je
vous montre très rapidement ce qui se
passe ici il ya le projet ventures qui a
été déclenchée par cause d'une grande
sécheresse incroyable qui se passe en
ethiopie sailesh derrière et on a levé
172 milles euros je crois ce qui à
l'époque pour nous était impensable
surtout en trois jours et en fait c'est
comme ça qu'on a eu l'idée de ziv en
2017 et on a monté le premier événement
comme ça pareil dans le garage fait à la
main ça faisait hyper underground roots
et et voilà c'était juste les potes qui
se réunissent à nouveau jeudi clore la
cérémonie le biais veut-il sont
l'événement ouvert messieurs allez sur
vos live c'est parti c'est né comme ça
mais ça vient juste d'un désir personnel
de zéro à tort et moi même de soutenir
une cause parce qu'on trouve que c'est
important de le faire on n'a pas les
moyens
c'est un tour à vis de ses pairs mais ça
permet un petit peu te de faire
connaissance avec des smartphones
connaissaient pas ou juste passer un bon
moment sur le stream ça vient un petit
peu unifiée toute cette communauté voilà
en rapprochant te laissera donc c'est
cool
lüthi ya dix-huit personnes au caire
aucun c'est plus que la finale de los
moros lee non je pense sur [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial mais ça ne m'étonne pas
parce que je sais que justement toutes
ces communautés sont extrêmement investi
c'est à dire qu'à l'heure actuelle a
énormément de gens qui regardent tous
les deux chez garde youtube qui sont sur
les réseaux sociaux
moi je débute en 2011 2012 et quand je
fais le comparatif ça a rien à voir on
avait des vidéos en qualité des gueux en
480p construit mais sur des plateformes
comme dailymotion
vu l'évolution spectaculaire là en cinq
à sept ans je me dis que dans 10 ou 20
ans ça peut être ça peut être hyper
impressionnant avec des prod encore plus
folle avec un public encore plus vaste
et surtout avec une diversité encore
plus large de jeu de type de format de
profil qui travaillent dans cette
industrie
deux chaises domingo ouais c'est faire
une course de chaises seychelles sont en
ville j'ai pas d'amis on le fait ou on
le fait là
chanter changer d'état qatar du permis
toujours explicables niveau de l'andi la
première breloque et la fin
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au repos
j'étais en situation de soulvache est
j'ai plus de chance du coup l'avantagé
c'est qu'on est très créatif chez les
français on se tire tous vers le haut en
voyant que avaya intel qui a fait ça
c'est trop bien gotaga qui a fait un
gotha gachot un show monstrueux sur
forte net il fait deux cent cinquante
mille dover tous les créateurs de
contenu regarder se disent ah ouais même
s'ils jouent pas fortuite ou hot c'est
quand même génial ce qu'il a fait et ça
donne des idées ça donne des envies
zerator qui organise la cci event les
ilan et trackmania cup
donc voilà ça donne envie de faire des
choses en fait on a le rush du million
qui arrive on a du coup le frère
englouti de rester unis va la faire du
coup là on va booster les dons
merci car pour les 10 euros merci lukas
pour le 20 euros six minutes avant
ces mamans tous les sites les années 50
l'éclat
[Applaudissements]
ses attentes et à tous merci à ceux du
matin sur féroce
incroyable
[Musique]
j'étais dans ma chambre qui à dix
minutes à pied
je suis venu en trois minutes ch pas on
m'a dit il ya bientôt le million dépêche
toi j'ai couru je suis mort la somme
levée est incroyable on a tellement en
avance par rapport à l'an dernier va
falloir faire mieux l'année dernière à
la même période on était un genre 400000
euros donc ça rien à voir il arrive en
courant les transports doux frais ok ben
repose-toi ses enfants
où
moi
vous
[Musique]
il va falloir les données sur le stream
de cam est tous d'accord ah ça y est ça
y est inconnue et aucun veto ok dit
quelque peu pour les streamer attend la
main c'est qu'ils font ce qu'ils
appellent des règles donc en gros ils
encouragent leurs spectateurs
allez sur les directs judge animateurs
pour ce il arrive à atteindre leurs
objectifs qu'ils se sont fixés
financièrement et en général vous voyez
dans l'objectif atteint ils ont engage
donc par exemple kamel rentrer à
marseille en vélo jamais eu leur permis
allez
[Applaudissements]
c'est une belle courbe de dons est à la
fin j'en fais déjà limite exponentielle
en est là c'est ridicule ça m'arrivait
aucun sens 16h 22h il est à tous et bien
arrivé
[Applaudissements]
c'est
2 millions d'euros allaient me contre
bilbao 1500 mal
ils valent ça s'emballe
[Applaudissements]
on a doublé l'année dernière 3 2
millions d'euros récoltés passa juste
monde est content incroyable royal juste
content de faire ce qu'on fait est
content de voir qu'ils avaient été aussi
a aussi génial
je me suis dans leur délire donc ses
élèves on a fait preuve de l'unité à peu
près 5000 euros en 2h02 trois heures qui
est incroyable je crois qu'il est temps
de vous révéler le montant des
tee-shirts on a gardé un petit peu un
petit peu secret pour tout le monde et
de 510 millions comme la cagnotte la
montée attendue à 4 5 millions en dépôt
mais vous a peut-être est-ce qu'on l'a
trouvé ce rendez-vous du matin
[Applaudissements]
les gens sont tellement généreux que des
1500 euros des 1000 euros d enfin c'est
juste fou que les gens soient soient
réunis autour d'une cause qui est
positive et ça renvoie une image qui est
super pour le gaming et pourra pour tout
ce qu'on fait dans le streaming
quand il faut se réunir pour pour le
bien on sait le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bahia
yes
ces jeux
ses papilles et encore ces sacs et
housses chez pias encore une heure et
demie il reste encore un peu de voir
trois millions ram c'est incroyable donc
3 m j'sais pas quoi dire mais c'est ouf
c'est vraiment vrai c'est vrai que la
cfu l'émotion qu'on va pas se mentir 3
millions j'ai même pas tweeté donc
imaginer confia atteint à demain que bfm
sauf peut-être un article sur les jeux
vidéo qui rendent violent mais bon
maintenant on a levé 3 ème nagano se
rapproche peu à peu de la fin du g20
malheureusement on a levé 3 millions
c'est génial donc organiser sa son geste
ici sert à tort et bâches on peut les
applaudir s'il vous plaît quand même mon
objectif ultime
si ça vous en bien on est globalement à
250000 pâle mais qu'il a fait le retour
de tous les dons c'est bientôt le rush
bien le rôle et de monitoring messieurs
deux années toutes ces causes la meute
c'est tellement à coeur
j'imaginais pas quel point vous avez
changé ma vie et à quel point on vient
de changer la vie de plongeurs et voilà
on va les dépasser 3
croyant
[Musique]
basa
là
merci à tous mais c'est aussi grâce à
nous c'est grâce aussi à tous les
joueurs qui sont là
applaudissements pour les joueurs c'est
leur foi merci beaucoup
une fois j'ai bien un truc dans un live
c'est et vous fait de nous vit un rêve
on essaie d'embellir les vôtres et je
pense que ce soir c'est hyper vrai on a
essayé de tout donner à fond pendant
trois jours tous ensemble pour lever des
fonds pour l'institut pasteur et ils ont
dit sont très reconnaissants de ça on
est tous très émus d'avoir pu le faire
grâce à vous donc merci encore jeune et
claviers veulent terminer pour 2019
merci à tous merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir participé à tout ça
c'est la folle you were you were you
were les viols les bureaux les viewers
les viewers c'est la porte de la chambre
à part
[Applaudissements]
mais voilà mais c'était sûr en fait
c'était sûr
[Applaudissements]